welcome to this video and maradona from
Iceland okay at the moment I'm trying to
experiment a little bit here with my
wide openings want to play something a
little bit different I played the troll
and this is this has a funny name it so
the the tarts on variation I'm not quite
sure why it is called like that but it's
called the tart sonotek like them this
famous figure from from the old old
movies from 30s and not not only movers
also books of course but okay 925 black
IAM has a slightly worse structure but
mine idea is this really okay so he's
accepting a further weakening of the
pawn structure man i didn't have so many
squares possibly um okay so should i go
see for here or not hmm can also try
quincy three yeah quincy three actually
maybe for queen bee hive i have p 3 and
then Bishop c4
yeah what is this actually if I if he
takes it if he takes on c5 is this a
good position yeah it should be good
Armenia if I doing this taking on c5
this is a good end game for white oh
this is a very nice end game I can put
my ping on c3 Bishop b2 and this is
something that I can I can down forever
and ever with b4 b5 and so on yeah
ultimately a 5 is questionable actually
this might allow a foreign b44 pesum but
ok let's let's see what happens what I
want is to trade some stuff here and he
is preventing it probably correctly
mmm-hmm ok don't deform yeah one thing
that I didn't really take into account
that much is that he does not need to
try it that's definitely true so now Kim
I'm going to play before he takes it on
par saw this is this is nice for me what
I'm arguing is that my majority these
three against two is some a little bit
more dangerous than his five against
four might be true Madden might might
not be true let's see
fine
my a to pawn this could be a problem i
wonder if i should is maybe see
preparing that I don't know b5 it takes
it I've always do before before in
Bishop's right now okay I can't play b5
can do that I was wondering if Bishop
deep one and and things like that if
this is an idea
hmm what is this move exactly wants to
go to e5
okay if I if I'm just take their taking
c6 I don't know about that
six more difficult and ok I'm going to
take this instance may be debatable it I
have to play them at some point I think
this is really more tricky than it looks
this position do I get the a porn yeah i
also have worked b7 this is one of the
ideas hmmm also I'd love to trade one
pair of rooks and just get the apron I
get the apron it will be very nice oh
very nice this may be an exaggeration
but at least I think I'm I'm totally
fine rope design or not might just take
here
at the end I just want the apron not
more not more nothing more nothing less
takes takes rook c5 rook e8 will get the
point if you move the rook somewhere a
playbook one to be five try to follow up
with King bee form a very difficult
position rather an unconventional
it's not so clear how I continue from
here do I continue Brooke a five is not
helping maybe I can regroup here who
could be d 1 B 1 B 3 or something at
least his rooks I mean they they they
are not really well placed time warning
I can always play this and it doesn't
lead Jack to anything here for me please
I don't see anything look before I mean
not accomplishing much okay I get one
look traded that is actually what I
wanted not sure if it as mentioned if it
is so hugely beneficial but it was about
it is what I wanted that's it's that
should be ok right if I have I get this
but how do I actually when I can go to
d4 that's probably quite ok rugby 6
coming check
okay going to the seventh black resign
yeah I don't know it was a tricky
endgame I felt like I should be somewhat
better but I don't know very very
difficult at least for me I mean look at
all at least I couldn't really evaluate
it Jack correctly I think so if I think
maybe around here I'm i can improve
maybe I should play be three for example
as a precaution this this I don't know
Jim now I went before and he played this
a 3 moon gem interesting it's
interesting that the computer has an
entirely different approach it plays
have three I am I thought about this
idea a little bit later when I was
thinking that maybe I should activate my
bishop somehow the idea is that this in
fact is quite nice and something like
this the c6 is really a problem that's
interesting and probably leading to an
edge but after f3 having and he does not
have to take if he don't say ignores it
also there's stuff like in form which is
probably something that helped me a
little bit or the computer suggests in
this war maybe trying to prepare that
yeah I have some I have probably some
advantage there yeah and and if this is
so great I don't know
yeah here I was thinking ok the computer
is not really agreeing with everything
with anything here it wants to just do
that ah you know what I you know what I
missed haha I wanted to go King here and
takes but he can go over to the Kings
side ruga f5 in particular this is this
is what I this is something that I have
totally missed that's good for black so
this was a mistake he could have taken
yeah and here Roxy 50 can still take on
CFO I here again f3 was interesting this
has no square hehe it was the point
where I thought about it but I thought
that he can just ignore it i mean this
would be it would be great yeah just
wrapping this route but I thought he can
just ignore this and I don't ever want
to take its may be interesting anyway
but okay this isn't this isn't a bad
move around here i think i should be bet
I am well the comp gives me a complete
win like night rook 5b seven Bishop d1
Bishop c2d aid yeah blackest is
definitely am NOT not in great shape
yeah I didn't didn't explore it and that
much only here I'm back on track again
it was a little bit more difficult for
black to play definitely okay i hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching